As you continue learning about EDA in the next
lessons, you'll get to hear from Moira. Moira's done
some exciting work at Facebook and she'll be sharing
one of her projects with you. Let's hear from her.
>> So one of the things that I've been looking at
lately is whether people's perception of their audience on Facebook matches up
to the reality. Who's actually seeing the content that they're sharing. Because
who think is in your audience really affects how you present yourself.
So to investigate this problem, I worked with Michael
Bernstein, Brian Carr, and Eytan Bakshy. And together we
ran a survey where we pointed people to a
post that they'd made in the last couple of
weeks, and we said, how many people do you
think saw this post? And then we took their
responses to that question and we actually counted how
many people had viewed that post for about a second
at least and we found that there was a pretty big
mismatch between people's perceived audience
size and their actual audience size.